bootleg Cav we got a my guy Dilo just
got home man he got new music coming big
big single coming with G-Eazy and insert
somebody from LA
[Laughter]
we won't say who it is I know who it is
now though but we won't say who it is
what I will say though is sounds like
it's going to be big that's what I'm
gonna say but yo usually when we do a
freestyle we just have people throwing a
beat and go crazy but my guy you've been
locked up you've been writing I'm sure
your your notepads had have been crazy
when you got out not really not too
crazy okay too busy on the phone no I'm
just more so to go in the studio right
then and there and do it like I I was
writing you feel me but look let's do
some acapella [ __ ]
all right um
free My [ __ ] Mozzy man free Mozzy man
freeing I say uh
little [ __ ] heavy metal messy murder
scenes he lied about the bodies he got
[ __ ] that's perjury for certainly my
Shooters caught him slipping started
squirting him his white tea was white
but we turned that [ __ ] burgundy we pop
bottles then went to Benihana's to
celebrate posted it online they tried to
slide but they was hella late Hellcat
foot to the pedal make it accelerate
pull up on the suckers bounce out don't
hesitate check my resume [ __ ] I've been
putting in work I've been put a [ __ ]
face on the shirt dick in the dirt it's
a cold game I'm funking with [ __ ] who
ain't got no aim walking [ __ ] down
introducing to this close range hey body
for body body we body [ __ ] I would give
props to the Ops but them [ __ ]
bodyless homicide questioning my [ __ ]
about a murder case we 30 deep on a
deuce and Burton look like it's Burger
day where my brother brim I need a eight
ounce of that sticky [ __ ] fully auto
Glock no stock just a 50 [ __ ] broke
[ __ ] hit off EDD Nikki Filthy Rich my
pocket full of Cheesecake I got it out
my Philly [ __ ] 2500 on my feet these
exclusive [ __ ] Ain't got these dropped
a [ __ ] off on the blade man they're
walking until she knocked me slapped him
[ __ ] Hood we won't stop shooting until
the block bleed police get behind me and
it's Hellcat imma show them top speed I
mean Louis gonna blow a bag they brought
me a glass of champagne I'm in the mall
strapped up with two lines on me like
I'm Max Payne I was taught by the best
and I do it better like the Karate Kid
choose with me give me ten thousand let
me get your body there got a suitcase
full of peas what you mean [ __ ] I'll be
moving them she'll never go to church
only Christian she know it's lubricant
my chain look like shiny ice cubes all
about my Benjamins I'm drunk off a whole
fifth of Hennessy I'm belligerent like
who you shoot who you kill you ain't got
no bodies dog you ain't sipping syrup or
popping perch you popping Tylenol just
knock the new [ __ ] got a busting dates
right after truck stop popping panels
off my rental car trying to make a tough
spot hey fresh out the pen you know my
pocket full of Franklin's look baby
hurry up and pay I ain't got no patience
hey these margielas on my feet ain't got
no laces look I like my [ __ ] black
and white cause I ain't racist hey man I
swear to God I hate a pretty broke [ __ ]
she'll suck a dick for free but quick to
talk bad about a hoe [ __ ] hey I just
popped the Adderall like I'm a college
kid I kept a tour I never went to school
but I bet my mama did I [ __ ] I done did
some [ __ ] that I can't rap about apply
pressure on my oppositions had them
tapping out [ __ ] took me shopping used
her credit card and maxed it out when
[ __ ] come to Oakland I'm that [ __ ]
that they asking about what's up with
all these sis we only do the VVS on
Gucci down came a long way from shopping
at DDS I seen the [ __ ] get his head
blew off at a Sasha I was hella young it
made me want to slide some Glock 21 22
and 23 got a chop aboard them bullets be
shooting through Big Trees [ __ ] please
caught a [ __ ] body and I'd like to
point out
if you got girls catching dates at the
truck stop we call those [ __ ] lot
lizards
a lot lizards shout out to the lot
I know you just watched the freestyle we
got another one coming next week
presented to you by LRG don't forget to
use my promo code at L Dash R Dash g.com
go to their website it's in the
description below and use the promo code
bootleg you'll save 30 off and they just
drop these look at these basketball
shorts boys these things are crazy you
know what I'm saying lrg's [ __ ] back
so why don't you go ahead and uh go get
you something 30 off right now